be starting now
hello everyone my name is jonas korloff
i'm chief scientific officer of pacific
biosciences
and i'd like to thank the organizers for
giving me an opportunity to speak to you
today
with regard to crispr cast 9 related
topics
my talk has two parts first i'd like to
talk about
the importance the challenges and new
solutions to measuring outcomes of
crispr cas9 experiments
and in the second part of my talk i
would like to mention new methods that
can
leverage the specificity of the cas9
enzyme
for targeted sequencing of previously
very difficult regions
so for the first part as an introduction
i think you all know that crispr
experiments are very easy to carry out
and i've just
highlighted two examples here in the
popular press
gene editing is so easy to do that we
couldn't stop if we wanted to
and there are even these homebrew mail
order crisper kits and so forth so
allowing absolutely anyone to hack dna
and so that
that just is a and there are many
research papers obviously and and
commercial kits now that
you know highlight how simple and how
straightforward it is to do these types
of experiments and edit
the genome of different organisms
however
it needs to be recognized that it's much
much harder to measure
uh accurately and comprehensively what
actually happens when you do such an
experiment
and you know there's one desired outcome
which is the editing of the target
region but
because the crispr cast 9 enzyme system
introduces double strand breaks in the
dna it has been recognized that there
are
potential undesirable outcomes and they
are categorized
at occurring either at or near the
target region the region that
people are interested in editing and
i'll refer to those as on target regions
and then it has also been described that
undesirable events outcomes can happen
far away from the target region and i'll
refer those
to off target events and so this was
described a couple years ago
on the right you see a nice article
by the scientists new methods off-target
mutations
where the the article describes
bioinformatic methods software methods
to predict um uh similarities of the
guide rna and so forth and uh in vitro
and in vivo methods to try to measure
these off-target mutations
what i'd like to do in this talk is to
tell you about a few new methods
and papers that describe doing this
comprehensively across the entire genome
and doing it with new methods
that give a essentially a better um
magnifying glass as you see it here in
the picture on the right
to see um better what the outcomes of
these genome editing experiments
are so i'd like to just very briefly
touch on
four papers and with the limited time i
can't go
in detail it's basically meant to give
you a teaser and if you're interested
you can
read those papers in more detail where
this has been described so there are
a number of examples over the last
couple years
where this has been investigated and
specifically using
new sequencing techniques so this is a
paper a couple years ago
in nature biotechnology a repair of
double strand breaks induced by crispr
cast 9 leads to large deletions and
complex rearrangements
so this paper is looking at the on
target undesirable effects
and you can see on the right side here
in this graph
there are two stacked images the first
one on the left
is looking around the target region
which is donated by the black lines in
about five or six kilobase scale so this
is looking
much further around that region and the
stack on the right is looking at 100
base pairs and so
you can see that when you only look at
very closely
you know in at the target region it
might not look so bad um
and there may be a little bit of a
depression but things look reasonably
okay
however when you look at it further out
around this particular region you see
that there are pretty large depressions
of reed coverage
and breaks in the read coverage and so
on the left side on the bottom left are
just a couple of the
undesirable effects that these
researchers recognized
where portions from a completely
different gene
in the top were introduced at the break
site
and then the second and third are
inversions either small or large
that were introduced by the crispr cast
nine
and so looking at this region with
longer sequence reads
um and sequencing that full length gives
you a better magnifying glass of what
actually happened
and so um just one more figure from this
paper
um you know if everything worked well
you would just see a dot
and the lines uh and the colorings
indicate that
there's a quite a variety of different
effects that can happen
both deletions uh in black and
insertions in orange
and so these can now be measured and
quantified
and then obviously that is a foundation
to then
adjust the experimental parameters to
minimize or
fix and avoid altogether these types of
undesirable effects
similarly a newer paper from this year
i'm from a chinese research group
also looked at cas9 cleavage
products and also find large fragment
deletions very similar
with these types of plots again the
coverage plot in orange on the right
uh you have the extend of the deletions
and you see again on the scale bar in
the bottom right
uh six kilobases so you really need to
look at it
at the kilobase scale which now can be
done um for example with pec bio
long read hifi sequencing to really
comprehensively and accurately identify
what happened at the site
that was targeted so again this is an on
target
method this was a much earlier paper
really pioneering um
in metfordius lab from stanford and nail
hindu
in cell reports uh characterizing and
describing smart sequencing in
particular
as a great way to quantify genome
editing outcomes
um they describe the system uh to work
on for all the common nucleus platforms
so not just crispr cast 9 but also zinc
fingers and talons and so forth
it can detect large insertion deletion
gene editing events
because of the long read lengths from
smart sequencing
it's broadly applicable to any cell type
and adaptable to any target site
and again it allows them for
optimization of these parameters to
minimize and it's highly accurate fast
and expensive
on the right what you see in the cyan
color
are the different off-target effects and
again these can be fairly large
pieces of dna that are being inserted
during the repair
process of the double strand break
and then the last paper that i would
like to mention and this is a new paper
the preprint
uh by eda hoyer and uh adam amir is the
senior author and i believe
adam will adam is speaking at this very
conference so i
would imagine that he's going to discuss
this paper in much more detail
but in this paper um looking again at
unforeseen crispr cast 9 off target
activity
they not only look at the genome y by
sequencing the entire genome
in a reference free unbiased fashion but
also describe that the difference
in the sequence of the two different
alleles the maternal allele and the
paternal allele
have to be taken into account when you
want to look at
off-target activities because the
similarity of the sequence
relative to the guide rna will be
different in some cases depending on
whether you're looking at
the maternal allele and the paternal
allele and they they show this figure
shows
that you can have very different um
activities
on the two different alleles so
more from adam i would imagine in this
conference and it's a really
uh really terrific preprint that i uh
and very recent work that i would
encourage you to
take a look at so in summary for the
first part of this talk
um it is important to measure the
outcomes
of the genome editing comprehensively
both with regard to on-target
and off-target effects because for
in efficient and safe procedures
you know you need to minimize and
eliminate those types of effects
and there are new uh solutions available
based on long read sequencing
that can measure these types of outcomes
at the multi-kilo based scale around the
target size
or as i mentioned in the last example
for unbiased genome-wide sequencing
you avoid bias by the reference genome
you don't have to map reads anymore you
can do the novo assemblies
you avoid allelic effects and so forth
and so i think that's really the future
of looking at um these types of
experiments and the outcomes of
crispr catholic experiments in an
unbiased and comprehensive manner
and just for um you know one
related note this month's cover of the
journal genome research
is an artwork by aran reeve who's at the
nih a co-author on this paper that's
shown on the right
about using high fidelity long reads now
to
assemble and characterize the human
genome much more comprehensively than
before
even resolving centromeres and and so
forth and so this is now possible and it
is efficient and it's cost effective
to no longer rely on uh shortly
sequencing and mapping to the reference
genome
but you can get a much more
comprehensive view of the entire
in this particular case human genome or
your genome of interest
to make sure that you're not having
undesired off-target effects
um or on target effects from crispr cas9
genome editing experiments
so in the second part of my talk i'd
like to switch and talk about
opportunities that can
leverage the really tremendous
specificity of the cas9
enzyme for targeted sequencing and in
particular regions
that are very difficult previously to
get any other way
and these are medically relevant for
example
in the neurobiology space there are
over 40 known inherited neurological
disorders that are caused by the
so-called repeat expansions
so these are simple dna sequences that
can be
expanded in their repeat and repeated
over and over
from under 1000 bases up to hundreds of
kilobases
and the length of those repeated
expansions determine the phenotype and
whether you have a normal phenotype
versus a disease phenotype
and the problem is that these are for
example the figure here you have some
triplet repeats or penta nucleotide
repeats
that because they
have a very low complexity or have an
extreme sequence
composition they typically cannot be
amplified efficiently or at all
with pcr and uh so
you can't you know amplify them out um
from um
the genome the patient and the uh a
person you want to
test um because of their the nature of
these particular sequences and so you
have to find
alternative ways to try to target and
enrich for this region and the cas9
enzyme
provides really exciting opportunities
there so
the way this can be done with a cas9
based enrichment for targeted sequencing
is that you have your dna of interest on
the upper left and the first thing you
want to do is block the five and
five prime and three prime ends of the
extracted dna you can do that simply by
dephosphorylation
because there will be a ligation step in
the future and
you want to avoid ligating all the all
of the dna fragments
and so we're going to try to enrich for
the one
squiggle there in the middle that has
the black segment which is the target
region of interest
and so then you design guide rnas two
guide rnas
that flank this particular region and
again
as you'll see with in conjunction with
long-range sequencing
you can design something that has you
know let's say four or six
kilobases um around the target region
um so you only need two guide rnas and
that piece of dna will be
enriched and excised in its entirety and
so there's no
assembly or no tiling required and so
forth
and so then you're taking advantage of
the specificity of the guide rna
to then cut make two cuts and
make a piece of dna that incorporates
the
that contains the region of interest and
significantly
does also does not have any of the
blocked ends
so that means it is available for
ligation and so
in conjunction with for example smart
sequencing you can then ligate these
airplane adapters they can have barcode
barcodes which are here
designated in purple which i'll talk
about in a minute
that allows for a high level of
multiplexing
which makes it efficient and so you can
see that there was no pcr
in at all in this particular um
procedure
and that's why i'll refer to it as the
no amp or no amplification
method and now you have enriched for
just the dna that's ready for sequencing
that contains the region of interest
so there are a number of examples here
this is a busy table but basically
this method allows for base level
resolution of the expanded genomic
region
an accurate repeat count identification
of interruption sequences
i'll talk about that in a minute i
mentioned it's free of pcr
so you don't have any pcr bios or
copying errors it's looking at the
native dna
as it is um as it was extracted from the
cells
and you can look at somatic mosaicism so
um
and it's it's amenable to multiple
kilobases looking at
a long long expansion so i mentioned
barcodes um
and so here's just one example of an
experiment where you can
multiplex both several targets
as well as several samples so
in this particular example we mix
together
12 samples and eight targets so in the
figure on the right you see the
different targets
fmr1 for fraudulex syndrome http for
huntington
c9 or 72 for als uh ataxin 10
for an ataxia nhva and hbb for
thalassemia and the last two are sip
genes for pharmacogenetics
and all of those targets can be
interrogated in a single experiment at
the same time that's all one assay
and of course with the um selection of
the guide rnas you can customize
what what genes do you want to look at
for this particular sample and can have
really high flexibility in customizing
the targets that you would like to
interrogate and then
the colored bars represent the different
samples so these are control samples
that you see on the bottom n a with a
number from the thousand genomes project
etc
and there are 12 samples and all of them
again are pooled in a single reaction
which makes this method really high
throughput and cost efficient
and on the on the left there you see
some stats about how many
uh you know total reads and reads per
sample
reads per target um but on the y-axis
on the right graph you can see that all
of the bars
are well over 50 and 50 is even
overkill for generating a high consensus
on both alleles
so all of these will give high
confidence
calls for the repeat expansions we have
developed
uh in addition some useful visualization
tools
so you can hear count on the
and and see the expanded repeats so for
three different examples
for the huntington's the first two and
then fragile x
you see the normal allele and then the
expanded allele on the x-axis is the
repeat count
unit and this you see that the peak
peaks are broadening
for the expanded allele and this is well
known in terms of the biology
that because you have a sloppy
replication that in the organism
in the individual the exact number of
reads can vary and you get a
good sense of how broad that how how
broad that distribution is
another way to look at this is in what
we call the waterfall plots
um so here you see the two alleles and
the wreaths
belonging to each allele stacked up
you see with the colored
so the gray is cgg in this particular
case on the left which is the main
repeat but in orange you see agg and so
you can immediately see that the normal
allele had two
agg interruptions because it has two
orange lines
on the top left and then the expanded
allele has only one
and that's significant for the uh risk
assessment of
how likely it will be for a mother to
give birth to a son that would have the
uh disease and so forth and on the right
for huntington's
you see a more complex picture with the
main cag repeat
in gray and then a number of different
sequence
triplets um as interruptions and that
all can be quantified and seen really
clearly
and then you know the typical igb
visualization so at the sequence level
you see how clean the hi-fi reits are
and then you can zoom in
and look at the sequence context and see
really with high clarity you can see
there are certain deletions
that correspond to the different lengths
of the cag repeats
you can look at the specificity of this
of the guide rnas very easily
across the entire human genome so in
this particular graph
you see the the human genome you see the
numbers on top of the graph
the chromosomes one two three all the
way to x and y
and then the reads um because they're
kilobases long you can map them uniquely
where they came from in the human genome
and in this particular experiment
four targets where um uh
four loci were targeted uh huntington's
als
scott 10 and fm01 and you can see
there's very good read coverage
and then by the errors donate um two
instances
in the human genome where there was also
read coverage
meaning there was some enrichment and
you can then look at those and find that
this was um caused
by uh sequence similarity of those
particular regions on chromosome 2 and
chromosome 9
having some similarity with one of the
four guide rna pairs
and you can look at the
sequence at the base level
you can quantify the off target effect
based on the height of the peaks
and so it gives you a really good
comprehensive and unbiased
view of whether you need to optimize
things further
now for the targeted sequencing that's
fine because you can just
remove those but again coming back to
the first part for genome editing
experiments
you would look at that and say well
maybe i need to optimize
my protocols and to guide rnas further
in order to
avoid potential of target effects
so um just to summarize
this method the no i'm targeted
sequencing method
allows for high level multiplexing
currently up to 48 barcoded adapters for
sample multiplexing
and for targeted multiplexing we have 18
validated guide rnas
available but as i mentioned it's
expandable and customizable
to other regions of interest and you can
mix and match to
your area of research there are a number
of publications already available so i
just wanted to include that here
and we'll make the slides available um
so you can click and learn more
about what the research community has
already achieved with this method
and we certainly see a lot of
opportunities
for the future so the summary of this
part too is that
this amplification free targeted
enrichment
leveraging the crispr cas9 enzyme and
specificity
can be used to target hard to amplify
regions
you have no pcr bias or errors you can
multiplex targets and samples
in conjunction with smart sequencing you
span the full region of interest with
high base accuracy and uniform coverage
and you can characterize mosaicism and
for the particular example
not limited to that of course but just
as one example for repeat expansion
disorders
it allows for accurate repeat counting
for both alleles
identification of interruption sequences
and the characterization of mosaicism
so with that i hope i've given you an
overview of these two topics
and as always um i understand that
questions can be emailed which i'll be
happy to answer
and so again thank you for the
organizers and
thank you for your attention
okay great job uh well we're all set
pretty much
from here i'll just do some quick
editing on the front and back ends and
get your presentation ready for next
week
wonderful thanks so much again nice to
talk to you again
yeah you as well if anything comes up
feel free to reach out but if not
we will go from here okay great thanks
so much
have a good day thank you youtube bye
you